[Musique]
et l'idée c'était de dire mais vous êtes
là poursuivre vos études et nous on a
pour mission de faire en sorte que vous
ne pensiez que ça
[Musique]
on peut dire j'ai des problèmes d'argent
mais on dit jamais je suis en précarité
menstruel entre un repas et et un paquet
de protection ont choisi le repas ce qui
fait que ce qui fait qu'on passe toute
la journée avec du sopalin du coton et
ça pour la confiance en soi c'est pas
idéal parce qu'on a toujours peur que ça
fuit et donc on se consacre pas
complètement à ses études en fait que
dans ce cadre là
où les mois moi je sais que je dois
acheter à chaque fois minimum deux
paquets de protection hygiénique et
c'est vraiment un vrai budget et rex est
un tabou ça c'est sûr il commence à être
levé mais ça reste ça reste un tabou
et justement c'est aussi ça le fait de
faire des distributions dans les halls
parce que c'est dans les halls des
universités donc c'est à la vue et au su
de tout le monde et les règles c'est
naturel c'est la vie c'est même grâce à
ça que les femmes peuvent avoir des
enfants donc voilà on assume
complètement et la distribution se fait
pas en catimini au quatrième couloirs de
la deuxième salle au fond
au contraire on voit là soyons fiers
d'être des femmes
[Musique]
or c'est à la fin c'est quand même une
question de santé parce que si vous
regardez par exemple un tampon trop
longtemps vous risquez un choc toxique
c'est les serviettes c'est pareil on
essaie de faire vraiment prendre des
prix assez bas et c'est peut-être pas
forcément le mieux c'est peut-être assez
irritant parfois et c'est ça fait du
bien con con une ce tribut des choses
comme ça ça nous fait du bien vraiment
ça ça nous allait jeter un poids si on
sait qu'on n'est pas qu'on n'a pas assez
de protection on n'est pas à l'aise de
toute la journée et ça c'est vraiment ce
que je veux éviter parce que on sait
bien que les femmes dans les études
c'est pas toujours complètement simple
on sait qu'il ya des discriminations
c'est qu'il ya du sexisme c'est qu'elles
sont confrontées à pas mal de choses et
ça ça on peut le résoudre
après le sexisme et tout ça c'est qu'on
peut aussi le résoudre mais sur le plus
long terme ça on peut le résoudre assez
rapidement donc allons-y
[Musique]
rien que ça devienne complètement
gratuit pour les étudiants j'aimerais
bien que dans chaque toile est femme
en fait il ya des distributeurs où l'on
puisse on puisse prendre ça on puisse
prendre des protections j'aimerais aussi
que les autres universités puissent
éventuellement réfléchir à le faire et
puis que ça suscite un petit débat parce
que dans les hontes non dit dans les
choses qu'on avoue pas facilement ça on
fait partie donc là je trouve que les
femmes valent bien qu'on leur offre des
protections périodiques